So far, we've been discussing the role
that the view controller plays as
the delegate and
data source for a table.
We've also implemented the methods,
number of rows in section, and self row,
and index path.
Now let's do something different.
In the favorite things app, the table
was already set up in storyboard and
you wrote the view controller code.
In the next step, Bond villains,
we'll do the opposite.
The view controller is ready to go.
Your job is to set up the storyboard.
This app displays villains
from James Bond movies
along with their evil schemes.
In the version you're about
to check out, the model and
view controller are complete,
but the table doesn't exist yet.